la star de cette maison plaisir ouah
c'est lui cristiano ronaldo tom williams
8 et 11 ans deux frères d'origine
portugaise ont de grands fans de
l'attaquant lisboète et de son équipe
nationale la ses crampons clavet l'année
dernière là c'est quand ils tirent des
coups francs et hier fort est là qu il
mène les accélérations avec la balle et
la cuadrilla lalanne les actualités
c'est ça au ballon d'or qu'elle a gagné
cette année pour ressembler au portugal
la passion ne s'arrête pas qu'aux
posters et olives les deux jeunes
passent également près d'une heure par
jour à regarder des vidéos des exploits
du portugal et de leur idole
et quand ils allument la console de jeu
le portugal est évidemment leur premier
choix
ils sont forts et à ronaldo là ce qui
fait des grosses râpé et dre il fait une
très très vite
pendant la coupe du monde en russie les
deux frères ont fait leur choix ils
supporteront l'équipe nationale
portugaise une décision qui ravit leur
mère je suis contente parce que c'est
vrai que moi c'est mes origines et je
trouve ça bien que les enfants s'en
rappelle est en tout cas le supporte le
portugal dans tout parce que c'est dans
le foot mais c'est aussi aussi pour
plein d'autres choses ils veulent tout
le temps les lab en vacances et adorent
ils veulent y vivre sur les terrains de
football yves binois les coéquipiers de
cristiano ronaldo également des
supporters depuis sa création en 1972 le
club des portugais de plaisir vibre au
rythme des exploits des lusitaniens et
non de l'équipe de france y en a
certains qui sont pour les deux mois
pour les deux j'habite en france et
voilà
notre famille portugaise on a du sens
portugais on sera toujours derrière le
portugal quoi c'est comme la plupart des
personnes qu'ils ont double nationalité
on a grandi ici
nos parents sont portugais on paie nos
vacances au portugal donc voilà c'est le
portugal a des qui a amassé le portugal
avant tout pour vivre cette coupe du
monde le club a prévu d'organiser des
repas devant la télévision les soirs de
matches du portugal mais ils ne
devraient pas être les seuls à suivre
les rencontres dans le secteur très
grosse communauté surtout plaisir les
clés et villepreux
il ya une grosse communauté portugaise
donc je pense que les veilles de match
où les sortez moi je vois tout ça ou
dans les cafés où j'ai regardé les mots
personnes avec plus de 4000 habitants
d'origine portugaise dans les yvelines
le département sera forcément partagé
entre le bleu et le vert et rouge
pendant cette coupe du monde